Ron
last name done
is that your name or are you telling me
you're finished talking both
done and done
I like Ron okay Eagleton Ron tell me a
little about yourself
well I love the outdoors love nature
amen I'm a big believer in Environmental
Conservation Recycling and composting
and like I'm a yoga nut
and I'm a nut nut
they make delicious milk man and I'm a
vegan of course slowly working towards
full freaking vegan what in God's name
is friggin vegan you only eat vegetables
that have been thrown out in people's
dumpsters what is on your foot sir my
trusty sandals the man's feet should
remain uncaged
same goes for all chickens well
we here in Pawnee value loyalty above
all else so would you be opposed to
signing an official loyalty pledge to
our new town as long as that new town
opened the ideals of communal living
everyone pitches in towards a common
good and the immortal words of Cat
Stevens if you want to be free be free
I no longer like Ron
what in the name of all that is Holy is
that smell yerba mate tea
sweet mischevia it's an all-natural
plant extract shut your damn mouth
no need to curse there most certainly is
I need Unity cookies with the Pawnee
towns original colors of blue and yellow
however I did not
testing so I had to use mustard but do
not worry I put tons of sugar on them so
it will even it out
um
sugar mustard it's awful kind of you
Leslie I'm afraid those are a little too
sweet for me unhook from that big sugar
train over 30 years ago you are a man of
principle and I respect that cool Ron
you can't force friendship Leslie it
takes time
I once thought I had a friend then it
turned out he was the single worst
person I have ever met I agree with Ron
Leslie
it's like Moz once said
hold on to your friends
Morrissey The Smiths you don't know Mead
is murder some of the best songs ever
written about industrialized beef
consumption okay eagle
just Ron has a position pretty much
locked up and uh I don't think we have
any room for you in our department fair
enough I should have seen it
tars and Capricorns they were mixed do
they
just remember Ron
giving it a hate
it's like drinking salt water
that there's only grows worse Leslie
removed this man before I commit an act
of violence against him whatever you do
I won't fight back
oh man this wine bottle is all out of
the wine well hello gentlemen
that brings you out on this fine evening
mother
whoa where'd you come from Ah that's a
complicated question all depends on
whether your conception of time is
linear or circular
what hello Ron Ron you know this hobo he
was my counterpart from the Eagleton
parks department to are you a ghost
am I
what is happening right now Mr Ron Dunn
I'm assuming I'm very angry about but
other on he's not helping me with it can
you help I can tell by the Indigo on
your chick lips that you've been
drinking blueberry wine
that's a good start the wall of Pope
called it matapiqua
they believed it had mystical Powers
Yeah it also tastes like jelly so what's
got your goat there friend my parents
they had this lake house and they sold
it without telling me so I was like why
you know it's like God you guys
oh you're hanging on to that anger for
dear life compadre
let's role play oh yeah
you're surrendering to the Earth Mother
stare into the fire and picture your
spirit animal I don't know what my
spirit animal is because it doesn't
exist because that's nonsense because
you're an adult
baby snow owl
that's right or Spirit Animals connect
us to the natural world
you need to remain open to their message
watch
welcome back old friend
if you really want to cleanse yourself
with that anger
take that check and send it into the
flames and up into the air with your
screams do not burn that check it is
money no Ron's right right
[Applause]
yeah there baby snow well
you're safe now
this is him right here
I'll also get out here and walk home you
sure this thing runs on vegetable oil
and bat guano actually cleans the air as
it drives quite sure thank you
hey
thank you for helping me with my anger
you already merged from your cocoon now
the question is
will you fly
yeah I don't feel any better I'm still
angry damn it [__] up Swanson it's like
you said death is natural and Sal lived
a good long life but so much is changing
and I've never been a fan of change
Salvatore
was a constant in my life in my
experience the only constant is change
now
nice to see you Ron
I couldn't help it over here I'm sure
I'm sorry about your loss and every time
we lose a Compadre or Collective Lantern
gets a little bit dimmer hey you look
awful familiar have we met before I'm
sure our souls have collided in one
lifetime or another no that's not it are
you in my frisbee golf league oh yeah I
play for the super Spinners oh I'm on
the Frisbee Champs oh cool I named us
Andrew stop speaking to this man he is
the worst human being on earth oh come
on death makes Brothers of us all I've
always found it when my soul aches was
lost
it's best to turn to Eastern wisdom this
is from the Isle of Isla and Scotland
this is as Eastern as my wisdom gets
Swanson this this handsome spiritual
Cowboy may actually be right about
turning to the east
I have an idea trust me
who cuts your hair little buddy whenever
my hair feels it has completed his
journey it simply sheds itself off I
hate you so much
and I love you my brother
this way please excuse me Ron I'm
talking to my best friends let me go
best friends attack Rock